spoke with one legal observer tonight
who was detained or gimana shares his
message and the response from Governor
Steve CELAC I'm glad that we were there
making a record of what the police were
doing public defender Christopher
Petersen volunteers as a legal observer
and says he was detained by Metro police
during Saturday's demonstration near the
Las Vegas Strip he tells me his role is
to document what happens and take down
the information of protesters who are
arrested you're not part of the protest
we are separate from the protest they
identify themselves by wearing these red
shirts that say legal observer but as
Saturday's protests turned tents
Peterson tells me he was caught in the
chaos he says he used a marked crosswalk
when approaching a police line near
Russell Road and officers allowed him to
pass through to the sidewalk but things
escalated just moments later 23 officers
came up from behind and detained me
pulled me back behind the line and held
me there I was surprised to be detained
at the time that I was detained he was
released with the citation saying he was
intentionally obstructing the roadway
the Las Vegas chapter of the National
Lawyers Guild says six total legal
observers were detained two of them were
taken to see CDC servers attorney Lisa
Rasmussen who represents some of the
detained legal observers calls metros
actions improper obstructing a roadway
governor excessive lack is also getting
involved he released a statement Sunday
saying in part quote any reports of
police action against legal observers
should be fully investigated and
reviewed so a full understanding of what
happened can be determined though
everyone has been released the legal
process isn't over yet and Peterson is
prepared we I'd be interested in seeing
what evidence will be presented against
me but we are looking forward to our day
in court
we're told Saturday night's protests
here on the Las Vegas Strip was the
first time Metro police detained legal
observers we reached out to Metro for a
statement about what happened but we
haven't heard back from them again
reporting live on the Las Vegas Strip
tonight orco mana 8 News now orco thank
you the American Civil Liberties Union
says they were monitoring the protests
happening here in Las Vegas they issued
a statement that said in part quote the
protests happening all over the country
are an outpouring of rage and grief at
the endless relentless examples of
unarmed black people being brutalized
and murdered at the hands of police
Metro police gave arbitrary and random
orders to disperse allowing crowds only
minutes to comply before police start to
detain demonstrators and quote you can
read the full statement on our web site
that's 8 News now.com